We're Doing something a little bit different today, New York City baby
We made it, just checking in, got some editing to do and we got to party tonight with Samsung
Here's the story guys
We're in New York City Samsung has invited us out because they're releasing their new
Galaxy s eight so we are just here as part of the party checking things out not really much idea what to expect so inside here
They've got really cool gear 36 earrings that I just tried that now they put me in a stunt plane
And it was like reliving my experience of my old airplane barrel rolls, hammerhead stalls, it was really really cool. They're treating us really well
There's a big event going on tonight. Not sure what's happening, but they also introduced the new gear 360 which is pretty much
360 Rig it will stream virtual reality, and it can do it live. Hoping they are going to give us one no free handouts yet
We're still looking
Brooklyn Bridge right here
Hey update guys. It's got a little bit dapper because we're over here at the Lincoln Center actually don't know what's going on
It's Casey's event tonight. We're talking [about] the new Galaxy S eight. I believe. Here we are
running around creators in
researchers
filmmakers and an artist and lola of what
my nine Dollar hot dog
Okay guys. We were back the trip is over that was incredible my first experience in New York City
[and] it was amazing and coming up with so many different creators to walk down on the Brooklyn Bridge City, too see New York City
The only thing I regret is they did not get to try the pizza
So I will have to be back for the pizza really big and sincere
Thanks to samsung because on my way out the hotel this morning
They handed me a brand new gear 360 rig and on the airplane ride home
There was an entire school group of people who are familiar with my channel
So we got a chance to take a big 360 selfie with all them and post on my Facebook page very cool
So I'm looking forward to exploring with this equipment in the future ton of fun looking forward to doing something like that again
And thank you for joining us on our trip to New York City. It was cool having you along
Hope you enjoyed some of the scenery. We look for a next [video]. Talk to you then?